hi everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm everyone makes mistakes in
chess even though we tried not to some
are easier to avoid than others but
every player is going to make mistakes
today we're going to be looking at the
top eight mistakes that chess players
make especially you're going to see
these a lot more with beginner players
more experienced players tend to try to
avoid these as much as possible but
without further ado the top eight chess
mistakes that players make
the first mistake a lot of players make
is to bring out their queen way too
early in the match they recognize that
the queen is the most powerful piece so
they play Pawnee for Pawnee five and
then immediately bring their queen out
to h5 hoping that their opponent makes a
mistake you know they could play Knight
here to f6 attacking the Queen and then
all of a sudden Queen here to e5 gobble
up some material and then check the King
the problem is if your opponent has any
sense of what you're doing they just
start developing their other pieces
correctly Knight to c6 great development
moves Center the board controlling this
square here then we see Bishop here to
see form trying to trap the opponent
with the Queen here to f7 but then all
of a sudden pawn to g6 then the Queen
comes back here to f3 because still want
to try to trap your opponent here on f7
and then Knight to f6
all of a sudden black is developing his
board very very easily white on the
other hand is just trying to bring his
coin everywhere in this queen is now
blocking the knight from getting
involved so whenever you're playing try
not to bring you're coming out very
early unless you have a really really
good reason to and more times than not
you're not going to have a good reason
the next mistake I see a lot is players
not focusing on the center of the board
pani for upon a five-night f3 and then
pawn to h5 this is an extreme example
but you can see black is not even trying
to focus on the center of the board you
always want to try to control the center
that's where everything stems from so
you're just gonna have a much easier
time if you focus on the center don't
try from the wings you definitely can
try to control with your minor pieces
but don't start moving your pawns on the
edge of the board early on it's going to
be very very bad for you
the next mistake players make is
forgetting to Castle now castling does a
few things one it keeps you from having
your king and the center of the board
just getting chased around everywhere
but it gives your King safety it also
gets one of your major pieces involved
into the action the rook they're very
powerful but they start on the corners
of the board and you have to try to get
them involved into the game or they just
kind of sit there and they don't do any
good for you so castling that only
protects you but gets your rook involved
into the game a little quicker so make
sure that for the most part you're
always castling again there are a few
rare exceptions but best practice
especially if you're a beginner always
castle
another huge mistake people make is not
protecting their King the pawns in front
of your king are very very valuable it's
okay to make some moves like pawn here
to h3 this kind of stop some of the
points like the knight coming here to g4
that's completely okay but you can take
this too far some players let's say
Bishop to d7 they'll start to push
forward pawn here to g4 castle on the
kingside pawn appear to g5 they really
want to force this knight to move but
it's come at the expense of all of the
safety in front of this King the White
King it's in a corner and it has no
defense eventually it will fall so make
sure that you treat the pawns in front
of your king with the utmost importance
they are really there to protect your
King at all cost so make sure again if
you lose your King you lose the game so
make sure you protect your king
the next mistake I see a lot of people
make is not thinking about their
opponents plan you should always have a
plan when you play but it's equally
important to think about what your
opponents trying to do look at this
board state if Queen plays Queen here to
H for a couple things happening one this
queen is threatening this pawn here on H
to four check has protection from the
bishop here Queen can immediately take
here on h4 if White's not careful white
may think this is a blunder by the Queen
on h4 but white has to keep in mind that
blacks plan is really to have all the
focus look over here because this Queen
is actually protecting the square here
on b1 if white comes over here and takes
on h4 all of a sudden White's going to
lose with rook here to b1 again this is
a very simple example but always think
about what your opponent's trying to do
and not just be tunnel vision on what
you're trying to do it'll definitely
improve your game a lot
another mistake a lot of players make is
moving their minor pieces more than once
in the beginning without any reason now
sometimes you may move that piece
because you're capturing a piece or
because you're setting up a trap and
it's going to end up being good for you
but sometimes players just move their
pieces over and over without any rhyme
or reason so you may play pawn here to
d3 Knight f6 moving you're not up here
to g5 there's no rhyme or reason right
now you're not trying to set up an
attack you don't have any other pieces
attacking pawn here to f7 Bishop here to
East seven Knight involved pawn moving
the knight back here to f3 Castle the
knight comes back here to d2 just kind
of moving your knight around this is
definitely going to be bad you can see
Black has a much better position here
than white why she's kind of moving all
of his Knights around doesn't have any
of his other pieces developed as a
couple moves away right now three moves
away from actually castling his King
getting King safety so black has the
upper hand where white kind of started
in the game so make sure you move your
pieces towards the center of the board
you control but then don't move them
again unless you have a very good reason
to
another big mistake that beginners make
is taking a easily one in game and
turning it into a still mates or a draw
and it may look like this white
obviously ahead we can all tell gonna be
an easy in game but because they rush
things all of a sudden Queen to f5 kind
of forcing the King into a corner which
is exactly what white needs to do here
the King's gonna come here to h8 and
then King to f8 and unfortunately this
is a drawn game black is not in check
and he can no longer move and so this is
going to be a draw game white does not
win this so need to be a little bit more
careful as far as how white plays you
don't always have to check your opponent
but make sure that if he's not in check
he does have a square or remove the he
can make so you don't end up with a
stalemate because this is very very
frustrating
the last mistake I see players make is
to fall for traps now traps are always
fun to play especially if you're laying
the trap but beginners they're just not
familiar with them now we've all kind of
tried the basic ones the pawn to e4 pawn
e5 get your queen involved into the game
and then after Knight to c7 or Knight to
c6 get your bishop involved and then
just hope and pray that they play
something on the Queen side so you can
come down here Queen to f7 checkmate you
win very very quickly the game is over
but a lot of times they're a lot more
subtle Pawnee for Pawnee five we get
into the Berlin defense and then all of
a sudden your opponent plays something
really weird they play Knight to g4 and
then you play pawn to h3 trying to just
kick their knight back because this
looks kind of weird and they play pawn
to h5 you take their Knight and kind of
chuckle and then they play pawn to g4
and you essentially lose the game and
you're just like man I just don't
understand what happened there Queens
come here to h4 after they move your
knight and then you're just going to
lose and so you look at this like the
fishing pole trap here and say man this
is a tough way to go so always important
to be familiar with some of the traps
one because they're fun to play yourself
but then too you just don't want to fall
for them and usually if you can stop the
trap you will end up with a better game
so always want to make sure there are a
lot of videos on the website the chess
website comm so look at some of those
traps and make sure you're familiar with
them you definitely don't want to be
falling for some of these traps so again
these are the top bait mistakes I see
from chess players that they make in
their own games especially a beginner so
make sure you try to avoid these and if
you see your opponent's playing these
hopefully you can take advantage and win
a lot more games thanks for watching
I'll see you guys in the next video